a little over three years ago tim cook
came out on stage and revealed a product
that kickstarted the apple silicon
revolution that we know of today this is
the new ipad pro yes that was the
freshly redesigned 2018 ipad pro that
outperformed laptop pc chips and
basically solidified apple's lead in the
professional tablet market but now after
two more ipad pro updates built on the
same design apple is finally gonna
redesign it again with the 2022 ipad pro
and this time it's gonna be a massive
redesign so the big question we've gotta
answer in this video is if it's worth
waiting for this new ipad pro or should
you just go out and buy the m1 ipad pro
right now instead so let's jump right
into it but before i get into the leaks
and rumors of the m2 ipad pro i want to
quickly sum up my experience with the m1
ipad pro model first off even though the
design is three years old it's still
incredible and many other tablet makers
are copying apple trying to make it look
as good so the design is awesome and
even though it's super thin we're not
having any issues with bending or
anything like that and it still feels
super super premium now i do love the
new ultra wide camera but the one thing
that sucks is the location which makes
it look like you're looking from the
side which makes it a little bit awkward
when on facetime or anything like that
now the new mini led display is amazing
and it looks incredible and the blooming
isn't that big of an issue but the only
problem is that it's only available on
the 12.9 inch model which does suck now
in terms of the speakers they are
amazing they sound absolutely incredible
and better than basically any other
tablet out there and one thing i really
like about it is that it's future
proofed with the thunderbolt port and we
were able to hook up the owc thunderbolt
dock and connect multiple different ssds
and things like that which was very very
nice and in terms of performance it's
super powerful and super snappy it's
literally the best tablet you can buy
especially with all the apps on the ios
app store and in terms of the
performance of the m1 chip it's
definitely overkill for a lot of people
but there are some apps like the game
gentian impact where you can max out the
settings and not get full 120 fps gaming
in that game like turning it up and
getting down to 35 to 40 fps according
to golden reviewer so with that said
there is still a little bit of room for
improvement but either way it's more
than fast enough for almost everybody so
with that said
why would you wait for the m2 ipad pro
if this one is so good well let's get
into those leaks now the first major
detail in terms of the redesign came
from mark german back in june 3rd as you
can see right here in this article he
said that it's going to feature both
wireless charging and reverse wireless
charging capabilities and you might be
thinking how is apple going to do
wireless charging through the ipad pro
well apparently they're gonna be giving
it a glass back just like we have on our
iphones now a lot of people might be a
little bit worried like what if it
cracks what if it breaks like why is
apple doing this it's crazy but they are
trying to make it more premium and
wireless charging does require glass or
plastic and they're definitely not going
with plastic now what this basically
points to in my opinion is apple adding
mac safe magnets to the back of the ipad
pro so you can grab your new air pods
with mac safe charging case plop them on
the back and literally recharge them
like that so that is awesome or you
could also just lay down the ipad pro on
the face and then put your iphone on the
back to charge that way and in case you
think that's an old leak that might
change from back in june german also
updated it back in september saying that
yes the ipad pro is coming and it's
coming next year in 2022 i know a lot of
people think it might be delayed till
2023 but here you go here's confirmation
from german himself and then finally
just two days ago german came out with
another power on newsletter and he said
apple is doing some crazy stuff with
future wireless charging according to
him apple envisions a scenario where an
ipad could charge an iphone and the
iphone could charge airpods and a lot of
this could happen truly wirelessly
without direct physical contact between
the devices so that is basically apple's
vision and that is just insane but it's
gonna take a while because german says
the company is likely to start with
inductive reverse charging just like
they're doing with the new mac safe
battery packs however cultivemac.com
just came out with a new article saying
that they think apple could potentially
give the physical maxsafe3 charging
connector from the new macbook pros like
this new 16-inch with the notch
to the ipad pro as you can see in this
rendered image right here because i
don't know if you remember this or not
but back in the day there was some
leaked cad files pointing to some weird
third connector right here in the left
corner of the ipad pro and people are
wondering what could that be could that
be an extra smart connector well if
apple does give a physical magsafe 3
adapter they could potentially put it in
that spot but then again that's going
directly against mark german who
believes it's getting wireless mac safe
but ed hardy did mention that apple
could potentially add both options like
it says right here apple could even put
both the iphone and macbook versions of
macsafe into its next ipad pro
which i kind of find hard to believe
because that makes it a lot more
difficult with the charging connectors
inside going to the battery and having
it split to different areas that might
be too complicated so in my opinion i
think it's more likely that it's going
to stick to wireless only and then of
course the whole point of that is that
you could charge the ipad pro through
the back with wireless charging while
you have the main thunderbolt 4 port yes
4 available to connect to different
products and ssds whatever you need now
moving on to a redesigned detail that i
have literally been waiting for for
years now apparently apple could be
working on an ipad pro with a horizontal
camera layout yes the camera being right
here in the center when in landscape
mode instead of being right here where
it is right now on the ipad pro which
honestly makes it so weird when you're
using the camera and using facetime and
it just looks like you're looking away
from the person and not paying attention
it is just so flawed i really hate using
it right now but apple could be changing
that and that rumor is actually coming
from the very reliable dylan dkt on
twitter and here you go that's what he
says and apparently apple could even be
giving the ipad pro a horizontally
placed apple logo on the back and that's
because apple is going to be completely
changing the software on the ipad pro
and making landscape mode the default
for ipad pro usage so they're basically
assuming that you're going to hold it
like this instead of in portrait mode
like this with other tablets and i think
apple is going to be doing this new
landscape default mode because they're
finally planning to release pro apps
from the mac like final cut and logic
which is something that john prosser
leaked
like years ago and we're all waiting for
it forever and i think we finally might
get it when they switch over to the new
landscape mode and that might actually
explain why they're adding wireless
charging so you can charge from the back
and then use the thunderbolt port for
pro apps like final cut or using audio
equipment for logic so it perfectly
makes sense and then on top of that i
was thinking about how apple could
implement xcode into the ipad pro and i
know that a lot of people are using
terminal and there's different code
structures and everything that's very
complicated but apple did actually
release xcode in the cloud recently so
they could just give you the cloud
version of xcode on the ipad pro and
then it's going to sync all the data
between your mac if you're using xcode
cloud there as well now i might be wrong
about this next detail but maybe apple
is switching up to the whole landscape
mode orientation because they're trying
to sell you on a magic keyboard case
because if they have it in landscape as
the default it basically needs the magic
keyboard to make the most use out of it
if it's a pro machine and that's another
300
profit or revenue for apple but however
the only unfortunate thing is that dylan
cannot confirm if it's coming in the
next 2022 ipad pro update or sometime in
the future but i personally think that
it's happening next year now like i
mentioned earlier in the video the one
downside with the current ipad pro
lineup is that the 11 inch does not have
mini led and that kind of sucks but
according to ming chakuo next year's
2022 11 inch is finally gonna feature a
mini led so it's not just gonna be on
the 12.9 inch and now everybody can
experience it so you could get mini led
with a nice portable form factor and
because of that i personally think that
apple is going to bump up the price by
at least a hundred dollars to 899
dollars as the base price because that
was the price difference that apple
raised on the 12.9 inch a hundred dollar
increase for the mini led so it's at
least going to be 8.99 or maybe even
9.99 for the 11 inch if that redesign is
really awesome and yes quo recently came
out in october and he confirmed that a
new 11 inch mini led ipad pro is in fact
coming in 2022 so that's very reassuring
and now the final thing we got to talk
about is the chipset and i fully believe
that it's going to be getting the m2
chip which is a literal upgrade to the
m1 i don't think it's getting any kind
of m1 pro m1 max or m2 pro because that
is just too much power to be packed into
a thin ipad pro so it's got to be the m2
chip and if you're wondering what that
new chip is going to consist of mark
german said that the m2 chip is going to
debut with the macbook air and it's
going to come with the same 8 core
layout so that's 4 performance cores for
efficiency cores but the gpu core count
is going to go all the way up to 10
cores so you're going to get a nice
boost in graphics performance for that
new macbook air as well as the ipad pro
that the m2 is going to go into but on
top of that we are expecting the new m2
chip to be built on a more efficient
process node which tsmc calls n4p now
some people were thinking that it would
mean that it would be four nanometer but
apparently tsmc said that they're doing
a third major enhancement of the five
nanometer process family so it's just
gonna be an improved five nanometer plus
plus plus which will deliver eleven
percent performance boost over the
original n5 which is the m1 chip so
that's actually pretty good
but on top of that it's going to give
you a 22 improvement in power efficiency
as well as a 6 improvement and
transistor density so basically you're
going to be able to get more performance
without overheating on the new m2 ipad
pro and you're going to get better
battery life and then finally the last
thing we're expecting for the m2 chip is
for it to be built on the arm v9
architecture so the entire core
technology is going to be different and
upgraded and it's going to be more
efficient in general and increase
performance and everything else just
from switching from rv8 to rv9 and
according to arm these new rv9 chips are
going to be coming out sometime next
year and a lot of people are speculating
that the apple a16 chip for the new
iphone is going to be the first with arm
v9 which means that basically the m2
chip is also going to be getting rv9
technology and now finally with all that
out of the way the last thing we've got
to talk about is the specific release
date like is it coming in the spring the
summer or the fall well if we take a
look at apple's release timelines for
the ipad pro there would usually be a
one and a half to two year gap between
releases for example the 2017 ipad pro
was revealed on june 5th 2017 and then
roughly a year and a half later we got
the 2018 ipad pro in october and then
around another year and a half later we
got the 2020 ipad pro in march now the
only weird thing is that it took a year
and one month from 2020 to 2021 to get
the m1 ipad pro so that was the first
update in a few years where it only took
around a year for the new model to come
out but since we are expecting the m2
chip to debut on the new macbook or the
macbook air and since a lot of the leaks
and rumors like this report from inquo
point to the new macbook air coming
later in 2022
i don't think that the m2 ipad pro is
going to come before this new macbook
and make sure that it's going to arrive
in the third quarter which is fall of
2022 so with that said i personally
think that the new m2 ipad pro is going
to be coming in at least october or
november of last year and that will
perfectly match up with all of the
different timelines and with that said
let's answer the original question
should you wait for the m2 ipad pro or
just buy the current m1 ipad pro right
now well if you're bothered by certain
things like the camera layout on the m1
being right here at the top instead of
on the side for landscape use then maybe
you should wait or if you don't think
the m1 chip is powerful enough or if you
would really like the new redesign like
the glass back with wireless charging
then you should probably just hold off
but in reality i think the performance
of the m1 chip is already overkill for a
lot of people so don't think that it's
going to be a huge improvement it's just
going to be a little bit faster for the
processing side and since we're
currently in the holiday times there are
a lot of deals and sales on the current
ipads so you should definitely check out
the sales on the current m1 ipad pro
down in the description below because
you could get a really really good deal
so with that said hopefully you enjoyed
this video on the leaks and rumors for
the m2 ipad pro and if you enjoyed it go
ahead and click the circle about to
subscribe and definitely check out one
of those two videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you